so und dann gab es diesen sommer noch
eine überraschende erkenntnis die ich
nicht abkommen sehen wasser ist bei uns
plötzlich ein knapper rohstoff wasser
schlechte nachrichten für die
veranstalter von wet t shirt
wettbewerben zum beispiel so ist das
halt nach dem dritten viel zu trockenen
sommer in folge schwer betroffen sind
unter anderem niedersachsen brandenburg
und teile von rheinland pfalz
deswegen hat die bundesregierung jetzt
den sogenannten nationalen wasser dialog
gestartet denn wassermangel hat für uns
bürger sehr konkrete folgen das kann
unter anderem auch bedeuten dass wir
einschränkungen bekommen dass man in
heißen spitzenbedarf zeiten keine
swimmingpools mehr befüllen kann keine
golf rasenmäher bewässern kann und
vielleicht auch keine daten mehr
bewässern kann und autos waschen kann so
ab jetzt ist der blöde klimawandel
persönlich so lange dass ein paar
kiefern im sauerland betroffen hat war
es mir egal alles was spaß macht golf
pool autowaschen der wahnsinns schlimm
wirklich landwirtschaft industrie und
verbraucher kämpfen jetzt vielerorts
regelrecht ums knapper werdenden us hier
zum beispiel aktuelle bilder aus
niedersachsen ministerpräsident stephan
weil auf dem weg zu einer wasser
krisensitzung in hannover gut in anderen
regionen sieht es deutlich besser aus
müssen wir sagen
wahrscheinlich brauchen wir auf dauer
einen neuen länderfinanzausgleich nur
halt nicht mehr in euro sondern in liter
schauen wir mal auf den dürre monitor
2020 so sieht er aktuell aus rot gleich
besonders trocken ja und da ist mir
jetzt fast total interessantes
aufgefallen meine damen und herren die
trockensten regionen deutschlands sind
tatsächlich ungefähr auch die region mit
den meisten afd wählern bei der letzten
europawahl
dann sind wirklich wirklich man könnte
also sagen wo dürre ist herrscht auch
geistige dürre will gott uns damit etwas
sagen ist nur eine frage
ich weiß es nicht ich stelle nur fragen
wassermangel neuerdings ein echtes
problem mit teilweise bizarren
auswirkungen auf den ersten blick ein
normaler einsatz wäre da nicht ein
ungewöhnlicher anruf kam über funk von
der leitstelle dass das einen anruf vom
wasserbeschaffungsverband getätigt wurde
und man uns androhte wenn wir weiterhin
so viel wasser
dass dann das wasser für uns abgedreht
wurde
willkommen in deutschland in ein paar
jahren ist wasser wahrscheinlich purer
luxus und am besten bereiten wir unsere
kinder schon mal schon darauf vor
gnadenlose frontalunterricht medizin
klempnow heute die schlimme wahrheit
über wasser freunde ich steig direkt mal
ein mit einem riesenkrach was der
unterschied zwischen mir und euch ich
krieg später rente humorlose kratzen
ok thema wasser ja denke nicht darüber
nach eine ist nass kommt aus dem hahn
bezahlen mama und papa falsch wasser ist
die währung der zukunft ihr müsst jetzt
anfangen wasser zu halten ja für später
ich leg jeden tag ein glas wasser fürs
alter zurück und als eisernen
notgroschen habe ich immer 50 liter im
tresor scheiße jetzt glotzt doch nicht
so ich meine das ernst
ihr müsst jetzt alle eure aktien
verkaufen und wasser investieren ja so
wie coca cola die pumpen in lüneburg
unser grundwasser ab und verkaufen es
uns dann wieder in plastikflaschen wie
geil ist das denn oder coca cola selbst
zahlt nur 9 cent für den kubikmeter auf
den liter umgerechnet 0,009 cent im
laden wird das wasser später für 85 cent
verkauft für das mehr als 9000 fache
wir werden alle reich nach nähe coca
cola betreiben so ruhe jetzt
wichtig ist dass wir alle zusammen
besser auf unser restwasser aufpassen
wenn ich zum beispiel sehr dass mein
nachbar das arschloch trotz wassermangel
seinen rasen bessert rufe ich direkt das
sondereinsatzkommando und liebe kinder
was denkt ihr wer ist das größte
wasserschwein auf dem planeten
naja war zu einfach
der nestlé-konzern über 7 milliarden
schweizer franken umsatz im jahr
nur mit wasser deswegen verlange ich von
euch das hier ab sofort folgende nestlé
produkte für immer boykottieren nesquik
kitkat after eight schoko croissants
sowie folgende eis marken kaktus mit
flippig sandwich caretta orange nicht
fertig in die smarties popup bum bum
[Musik]
martin klempnow so eine ministerin hat
sich während unserer sommerpause wieder
mal ein echtes fleißkärtchen verdient
julia klöckner in ihrem nicht müde
werdenden kampf ums tier wohl vorgestern
verkündet das küken schreddern soll
aufhören also das schreddern männlicher
küken nicht sofort jetzt frühestens ende
nächsten jahres vielleicht dann hat
klöckner allerdings mit dafür gesorgt
dass schweine noch weitere acht jahre in
sogenannten kastenständen gehalten
werden dürfen
obwohl das gerichtlich mehrfach
festgestellt und verbotene tierquälerei
noch acht jahre mehr
das klingt erstmal gemein aber eine neue
klöckner gast ii verordnung für hunde
gleich das völlig wieder aus julia
klöckners tierleben präsentiert von
dietmar wischmeyer
julia klöckner weiß was tiere wirklich
brauchen seit jahren sieht sich ein hund
und fragte mich schon was denkt dass
hier so in der wohnung man muss mit dem
gassi gehen wussten sie dass es nämlich
so hier vorne tut man dosenfutter rein
und das kommt dann hinten als braunem
ampel wieder raus ehe man sich versieht
steht man knietief in hundekacke da
musste eine lösung her deswegen
klöckners gesetz dass sie zwar zweimal
am tag und in bayern muss man zusätzlich
noch drei mal mit der frau heraus wie
viel spaß das macht sieht man am gesicht
das eingeborenen frage wer soll der
glocken aus katzwang kontrollieren das
sind die länder zuständig in der regel
eben mit der behörden der länder
die werden natürlich jetzt nicht wie sie
das möglicherweise befürchten dagegen
den hund hat klingeln und fragen waren
sofort mit ihrem hund schon draußen das
so ist es nicht gedacht was warum nicht
oder wie wäre es mit einer hunde stasi
sind doch sowieso alle gechipt kann man
super bewegungsprofile anlegen
hunde haben sowieso gut ganz im
gegensatz zum deutschen schwein dabei
sind die super intelligent und sehen sie
aus wie die meisten von uns also rosa
übergewichtig und kleiner ringelschwanz
der wird aber schon beim ferkel zusammen
mit den flöten ohne betäubung ab
gesegelt und als sau landest du dann im
kasten stand wo schwein sich nicht mal
umdrehen kann
doch der tag der befreiung durch julia
klöckner steht kurz bevor
wenn die verordnung in kraft getreten
ist haben die landwirte drei jahre zeit
dann muss das umbaukonzept stehen nach
weiteren zwei jahren müssen sie den
bauantrag stellen
nach weiteren drei jahren muss der stall
fertig sein
acht weitere jahre isolationshaft das
größte schwein ist und bleibt halt der
mensch nicht mal normaler sex wird den
armen säulen gegönnt der sause sind
prinzip egal woher wissen sie das man
kann sie aber diese sie sagt ich bin
jetzt stimulieren die pc-ware drauf
springt oder ich setze mich darauf und
bekamen so schmeckt die launischen
solange er über noch merkt dass er auf
einem schwein reitet ist nicht alles
verloren
das war klug nutzt ihr leben für heute
in der nächsten folge erzählt uns tante
julia
dann wie lange ein meerschweinchen im
aquarium überlebt
[Musik]
was ich über meinen arsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen ihr könnt ihr in der
zeit den kanal abonnieren
[Musik]